I have seen the shift where they're
talking about Maps minor attracted
persons and TED talks and all these
things they're saying we could we should
sympathize with these people and they're
just a sexual orientation sexual
orientation I mean this is wow sick man
where we're heading
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
another LED live light exposing Darkness
today we're going to talk about a very
controversial movie called The Sound of
Freedom lots of you guys have asked us
to review it so here we go
so I have seen the movie you have seen
the movie you guys have yet to see the
movie right
do you guys know why it's so
controversial
well we talk about human trafficking so
and then I mean people like to hear that
or maybe a big Corporation not working
right they don't want to you know spell
I mean you don't hear that very often in
the news so I mean somebody's gonna make
a movie about this topic I'm sure
it's gonna be a little red well I hear
two sides like it's controversial
because it's exposing the elites the
Jeffrey epsteins and all that and that
it's trying to get shut down and all
that but then I hear the other side
where it's like oh this is all
conspiracy theory Q Anon all that and
people are saying it's not even real I
don't know anybody could think sex
trafficking is not real if you've ever
been to the airport in Atlanta it's like
every 30 minutes or saying something
about sex trafficking it's very real
very real topic I think it's definitely
something that should get more awareness
about it so maybe we can take a quick
look we can see what the movie is about
that make you feel
[Music]
giving your child is free
zes is freedom good
you've been at this for 12 years
why are you doing it
because God's children are not for sale
it is the fastest growing International
crime Network that the world has ever
seen
I mean just the cow ended I mean it's
the largest
uh networking crime crime networking is
like the the whole world I haven't seen
I mean like this is insane right it's
really hard to believe though I would
think drugs things that would be a lot
more easier easily accessible would be
bigger but
maybe it's just the growth of it have
you found out who is saying that it's
controversial who's really pushing the
news that oh this is a controversial
film yeah so it's it's interesting it's
actually mostly media Outlets more
towards the left and more democratic
that seem to be saying these things
interesting okay and then the right wing
like the Republicans and the Fox News
are actually saying like no this is true
and we should be talking about this
um the movie is about Tim Ballard he
used to work for Homeland Security
investigations
and so he was working a lot with
catching uh Predators who were you know
selling or creating or consuming top
pornography and Tim Ballard came across
a case uh well in a movie they show you
I think it's a kid in Colombia I think
that in real life it was actually in
Haiti
um so he
um
came across this case of a young boy who
was kidnapped
and he's like I want to return him to
his father in the in real life the
Haitian kid was actually U.S citizen but
for some reason Homeland Security was
like no this is not a U.S case even
though it was a U.S citizen which is
strange and so when Tim Ballard quit his
job months out from starting to you know
receive his his retirement plan
and he ended up uh you know starting
operation Underground Railroad his
non-profit and so he uh Q Anon is now
promoting this movie right they're
speaking out saying yes we're so glad
that uh that there's a movie about sex
trafficking etc etc
and because of that wait so they weren't
necessarily involved they were not
involved no the actor though uh Jim
Caviezel
he is considered to have somewhat
supported Q Anon so so what's the
conspiracy here is it the details in the
film that's the issue are they saying
that it's not real because I mean that
would be pretty ridiculous versus is it
being real or is it the associations
like what is that the root of this
it's two things one is that the actor
Jim Caviezel has associated with Q Anon
okay that's an issue they say the other
thing is that Q Anon is speaking out
saying this moving is awesome and the
other thing is that people are saying
the details of the movie are incorrect
I'm not sure if this actually happened
or the numbers are off about human
trafficking Etc I mean it is a movie
it's interesting what people pick and
choose to say like oh the details are
wrong that's throughout the movie when
there are other movies that's what I'm
thinking like you guys have seen the
movie what did you see anything
controversial about it
in what sense because there's like
movies where people's heads are being
cut off and that's not controversial not
that I could pick out it's interesting
like comparing a movie like this to a
movie like uh nefarious both of these
were made by Christians but not
necessarily for a Christian audience it
was really just to raise awareness about
two different topics but when you look
at uh nefarious in comparison to
um sound of freedom
nefarious was like devoid of hope so
it's a really heavy topic about demon
possession and these things and capital
punishment but
you walk away from the movie with like
oh you know like just deflated so to
speak yeah
which you know I don't even know how
that could be a good thing if it's a for
from Christian creators sure it's not
for a Christian audience but it's for a
good intention like outcome I would
assume versus sound of Freedom it's
still it's a heavy topic you could walk
away from it very like Angry full of
emotion or deflated but at the end Jim
Caviezel comes up and he gives a message
of hope he gives action steps as to what
you could do to fight against this next
step so you leave you leave the the
movie theater not with any kind of
misconception that this like oh it's
okay like we showed all this stuff but
no it's not really that that bad yes
it's bad but here are action steps you
could take so you could feel involved
and to protect your community how you
can give back all this kind of stuff so
there is that element of Hope
um Christ is brought in as well so so
with I find it a good approach to
talking about every topic like that when
it comes to the conspiracy of like who's
promoting it that's interesting to throw
away the film because of because of
who's promoting it what what is it about
Q Anon what is Q Anon so I have a clip
uh actually in here uh where a news
anchor interviewed someone who runs a
podcast that discusses Q Anon
to look more closely at the rise and
spread of the Q Anon conspiracy on the
campaign Trail I'm joined by Travis view
co-host of the Q Anon Anonymous podcast
Travis welcome to the NewsHour you have
been following the Q Anon conspiracy
theory and its followers for a very long
time let's start with the basics though
for those who haven't been just explain
to us where and how did the Q Anon
conspiracy begin uh the Q Anon
conspiracy theory uh originated on 4chan
in October of 2017 though it has its uh
origins in uh in a pizza gate the basic
premise is that a group of high-level
military intelligence officials uh close
to president Trump you and the followers
believe are sending out secret coded
messages on these image boards about
this great uh Grand Battle of good
versus evil in which Trump and the what
they call the Q team are working to
destroy a global cabal of Satan
worshiping pedophile files which the Q
Anon Community believes is uh
controlling everything and that includes
politicians entertainment and the media
okay so I believe it
so so Q Anon believe followers followed
the queue believe that there's an elite
of devil worshipers who uh sexually
abused children right and it's like
politicians and and
um celebrities all those kind of things
so whether whether you know Q Anon
believes this or not doesn't take away
from the fact that there are people who
are higher up who are uh sex offenders
who also abuse children and I mean
that's just facts right like that
doesn't take away from the truth so
um here it's I have a couple names here
Corey Feldman an actor Corey Haine who
ended up deleting himself after
depression Joey Coleman Elijah Wood he
says he wasn't he hadn't experienced it
himself but he knew about it he was a
child actor uh Anthony Rapp uh mark
salling an actor owned child pornography
we know of Josh Duggar a former reality
TV star who owns the child pornography R
Kelly but he was later acquitted and
five years ago multiple families have
accused him of brainwashing and
withholding their daughters in what has
been described as a sex cult there's
also a celebrity sex offenders who have
not been immediately associated with
child's uh sexual
images such as Harvey Weinstein Bill
Cosby Mike Tyson Paul Rubens also known
as Pee-wee Herman the rapper Mystical
and of course Jeffrey Epstein who owns
an island that the locals called
pedophile Island I mean
I understand like kiwanon's I believe
it's a conspiracy theory and they go
really really far but the fact is they
are uh uh there is pedophilia happening
in Elite groups that is we all know that
so we can't that's the best way to
discredit the truth or to make the truth
like crazy is to put it in the National
Enquirer or make a whole
you know Forum this just it's like Alex
Jones like I really like it when I got
into conspiracy theories I was really
watching Alex Jones because everything
he said was provable is like here's all
these Declassified documents and stuff
like that but the way he presents it
makes it look crazy like they're turning
the Frog's gay like he's just freaking
out it's true atrazine is I mean you can
look it up PBS speaking of uh atrazine
is a pesticide that was getting into the
water and it was literally changing the
genders of frogs the males are having
babies and all kinds of stuff but when
Alex Jones is dressed like a frog and
screaming it discredits the message so
that's exactly what Q Anon is it's like
they're like oh Q Anon lizard people
taking over the world or whatever no
it's like the truth is buried in there
it's just to make it look ridiculous
yeah in my mind the way I look at is
let's say you have soccer right I'm from
Europe soccer is huge in in the
Netherlands
and there are soccer fans who come and
they are called Hooligans people who
destroy after a soccer match who just
like set cars on fire who cause violence
that particular group is called
hooligoods in in at least in Europe
that's what they're called
now the fact that those people come in
and do something bad like they are
destroying the place and there are
um you know putting a giving soccer a
bat Rap doesn't mean that the soccer
match never happened does it mean that
the team didn't win or lose or whatever
that's still a fact right it's the same
here just because Q Anon is coming out
and saying oh like it you know we this
is this actors from Q Anon and we love
this movie and support the movie
supporters like soccer supporters
doesn't take away from the fact that sex
trafficking is real and there's plenty
of evidence that what Tim Ballard did uh
helping those children Etc actually
happened
and if I'm understanding this correctly
the conspiracy within Q Anon is as to
who is involved in these actions not
necessarily the actions itself right I
think so yeah yeah but it's like all the
elites that because people just they
they have this bias they want to protect
Hollywood or whatever like people just
don't want to accept that their Idols
are but the other side of the coin the
idols have a lot of stake in the game
right so it
hey maybe I'm delving into conspiracy
myself that maybe they're the ones who
are stirring the pot so that this is
viewed as controversial and then the
message gets lost that the overall
message gets lost because people are
trying to discredit it and in all of
that noise and Chaos those people walk
off free yep so let's look at this next
clip this is uh Tim Ballard and he's
interviewed by Fox News and he's coming
out about this backlash that he's been
given uh by left media about the movie
sound of Freedom this movie zeros in on
the multi-billion dollar human
trafficking industry and honors a hero
someone who saved children from sex
slavery but to the media this person
isn't a hero someone who rescues kids
from pedophiles is a villain
these films are created out of moral
panics they're created out of bogus
statistics they're created out of fear
and with something like sound of Freedom
it specifically is looking at keyword on
concepts of these child trafficking
rings that are run by the high level
Elites for some reason the entire media
is smearing this movie as a dangerous
conspiracy theory the Press is saying
that the star Jim Caviezel is a q Anon
guy
and Jim plays Tim Ballard which is
strange because just a few years ago the
same media was celebrating Tim Ballard's
heroics watch
Jim Ballard has one mission to track
down child traffickers four months ago
Colombian authorities asked him to
investigate a tip that children were
being sold there as sex slaves within a
half hour
this individual walks up to me starts
asking me what I'm here for what I want
and within minutes he says well I've got
I've got kids as young as 11 years old
so why is the media warning people not
to see a movie about child sex
trafficking that's based on a true story
will the spear fun founder Tim Ballard
joins me now so Tim why is the media
hating this movie
you know I can't understand it the film
was made produce written like five years
six years ago way before anyone heard
the name kiwanana I still don't even
know what Q Anon is uh in the meantime
they're trying to connect it to some
conspiracy when in fact like you said
this is a true story these are real kids
I mean I'm these kids are my friends
they're young adults now the ones who
are rescued they're going to come out
soon and tell their story it's going to
be very awkward when the mainstream
media comes after these kids next and
accuses of them of being part of some
conspiracy when in fact they were
rescued from a life of rape it's it's
the most bizarre thing I've ever seen in
the media perhaps I mean this
publication says the sound of freedom is
a superhero movie for dads with brain
worms and that it fetishizes the torture
of its child victims is that what the
movie does
it absolutely does not do that it tells
a story based in truth and you know what
I think is happening Jesse I think that
the left and these these media Outlets
they don't want to have a discussion
that this film is going to compel a
discussion about why 85 000 children
showed up unaccompanied at the border
and got released into the interior of a
country that is uh the highest consuming
country for child exploitation material
on the planet they don't want to talk
about why these same Publications are
pushing an agenda to change the word
pedophile to minor attracted persons in
order to normalize sexual activity with
children I think that's what they're
trying to avoid and they know this
film's Gonna Shine a Light on all of the
things all the atrocities happening in
children and so they have to discredit
it by lying about it so what would their
motivation be to discredit a movie
that's trying to shine a spotlight onto
atrocities committed against children
well they if if if if the truth of human
trafficking and child trafficking and
child exploitation exploitation were to
be uh brought to bear brought to light
then they would have to have a debate a
discussion that they don't want to have
about again these policies around
sexualizing children or allowing
children to consent at a young age to do
anything and everything uh which would
eventually include being you know
identifying as an adult perhaps and
having sex with Benefits I hunt
pedophiles I've been hunting them for 20
years and they are watching this and
they're salivating they are happy that
Rolling Stones and the guardian are
ripping on a movie that exposes them so
I don't like the fact that these media
Outlets are in fact wittingly or
unwittingly running interference for
human traffickers and pedophiles wow
there you go that's great answer right
there yeah yeah that's not like a truth
bomb for real because I I have heard I
have seen the shift where they're
talking about Maps minor attracted
persons and TED talks and all these
things they're saying we could we should
sympathize with these people and they're
just a sexual orientation sexual
orientation I mean this is wow
sick man where we're headed
yeah we're gonna I don't know something
I don't know if if I missed it but did
you see in the film any scene of them
graphically showing any high up Elite
person doing anything to a minor like
the the movie is pretty intense but they
do it in a very tactful way where no
child actor had to depict anything
graphic to the audience like you weren't
necessarily exposed to the the graphic
nature of the content but you kind of
got the gist of what was happening so
for
to be highlighted that or that the first
guest that they had on the show when he
said that Q Anon ideas or beliefs are
are interjected into the movie I didn't
see any of that yeah the villains or the
people that were buying the children or
whatever were they he's like people part
of a cartel yeah it looks like the
jungles and stuff what I'm saying in the
videos now in terms of like the
statistics like
maybe they're thinking they're inflating
them or what have you but with the topic
like that it is very hard to get
concrete statistics in this in this area
are you a pedophile sir yeah yeah yeah
right like oh all these children are
trafficked on the ground but they don't
they're not saved yet so like you can't
know exactly how many children are
beating traffic right now you can only
guess and that's why so many statistics
even staying away from the movie right
staying away from operation on the
ground railroad if you just look at even
government statistics or if you look at
renowned organizations with their
statistics it's all different right so
like why beat on this movie when there's
other statistics that are different too
so it was a interview with the director
of the movie and they asked this
question how do you deal with the acting
of the children and because you know
there's heavy topics right
and if you're interested in this guy
said he said uh we didn't tell the
children whatsoever what the movie was
about hmm
like they didn't know anything the only
thing we asked them whatever scene it
was like for example I'm gonna grab that
or this person's gonna be mean to you or
something and we're telling like you
know what we we're filming this episode
and it's like uh uncle whatever uh they
didn't give you the toy and or candy or
something and it's gonna take you like
you know like he's so upset about it so
you get the emotion without traumatizing
the jokes exactly so for the child the
actor he's thinking about like you know
it was my birthday and I ruined the cake
they're like you know just be angry or
be upset or like be sad because you know
so they didn't know anything what it's
about you know
where where else in Hollywood do you
hear that that they actually treat the
children with so much respect and
dignity right seriously uh one one thing
that can be said though I did see an
article I believe talking about a little
bit of the corruption that was forming
or that was exposed within Underground
Railroad and on the news even recently I
heard about some corruption in so the
sober living program that helped and
take in um alcoholics and
um out in India there's a group that is
helping people who
by couples who come together that are
not part of arranged marriages and like
get become a safe haven for them but
there was some messed up stuff happening
in that so it's like yes these
organizations are run by people right
and it happens in churches right and so
things are going to happen and it is
unfortunate that they do happen and they
do bring a bad name to those companies
and a lot of times we we focus on that
and forget all the amazing things that
they were doing for decades before this
came out
so you're seeing the good with the evil
and I even heard that
what's his name Tim Ballard yeah was
kind of trying to remove himself from
the underground
to just focus on his work but it is the
underground Opera operation underground
to help the kids that's his ministry you
will literally go overseas and work with
local foreign governments to save
children from trafficking yeah but it
sounds like there's a reason that he
wants to separate himself from it is
there some kind of Tainted name with it
or because of the corruption that's
coming out about how they used funds and
all that kind of stuff it's his ministry
he started it yeah and he's the CEO or
what I don't know if he's still involved
yeah wow yeah so I should we should
probably Factor before we release the
episode if he's actually moving away or
not but yeah it's like sure like two
things can be true at once type of thing
like we can we can call it for what it
is think bad things may be happening but
also let that not completely overshadow
why the organization was was started how
many people they have helped and
hopefully like the result of calling out
the corruption is reform and not
completely just dismantling the whole
thing for for the problem to grow back
into the B said it once was yeah
so I came across uh operation
Underground Railroad and their work
years ago when a friend of mine told me
to watch this documentary and you know a
lot of these media Outlets are saying
like man this doesn't even happen and
this is false but whatever but you can
literally go to their YouTube channel
and they show you body cameras hidden
cameras that's how the movie starts
actually with the real footage of kids
being snatched off the street that's
right I love like security cameras and
people might say oh that could be
doctored it's false but it's like yeah
you then you could just go on YouTube
but the thing is that if it was false
yeah right I mean if it was false
the message is protect your children
yeah I mean yeah oh my God I mean
seriously I mean like a human
trafficking and people do you think
somebody just come up with that thing I
mean come on out of all the messages
that come out of Hollywood and we're
gonna attack the one that says protect
your children I mean it's it's nuts dude
so I want to show you guys a clip real
quick from Haiti how they did their
operation there these places are are
dark they're shadowy we have to assume
behind every corner is a thug with a gun
[Music]
foreign
do you expect that there'll actually be
children just sort of on display Once
you walk in 100 really if they catch us
recording something you wouldn't be
recording if you were a client that's
when they pull the guns out
that's when they realize you're better
off dead to them and alive
[Music]
yeah he's a room she's got keys to the
rooms
[Music]
so she's she's 13. 12.
scared of the water
[Music]
look at this
contain them in the room keep them
occupied keep them happy until we're
ready to proceed with the next phase
which is the arrest and Rescue
[Music]
thank you
come on in guys
[Music]
how old are they
what age what age did you bring 14 13
yeah I mean some of them are 11 I don't
know 11.
and you're the real thing so just tell
us what you want
you know you did that the boss doesn't
Booth give money on the boat you
understand that you got lots of money no
money on the boat the money's in the
house you're gonna get your money room
124. all right brother all right we'll
see you later man okay no problem
my Clockwork man it's kind of like
clockwork
okay so that's the first now if they do
good you get more more
here they come waiting the house right
now
oh
these guys of course will be taken away
to prison now and more importantly the
children more than 30 children we think
at this stage they're in the hands of
the people who can look after them and
hopefully pretty soon at least some of
them who perhaps have been kidnapped or
or even worse hopefully soon they'll be
returned to their families
it was just Elation to know that we'd
rescued 30 girls it huge and it's it's a
it's setting
um the standard now for Haiti well that
was intense right
and so people say oh this is not real
you kidding me I don't know I mean come
on like literally foreign governments
are involved but it's not real yeah
yeah in the beginning you say like who
you know you guys didn't watch a movie I
mean I don't need to watch the movie I
saw a lot of things you know them for
information I mean personally you know I
saw a lot of interviews and everything
this is serious topic and
um
it's very sad sad about the if you don't
believe it and it's very sad the facts
do because things happen yeah we watched
something where there was a grown woman
that was portraying herself as like a 12
year old on social media and she was
wearing this hoodie and using filters
and taking pictures and just building
her whole profile and as soon as they
went live within minutes grown men were
dming her and being like you're
beautiful and showing their yeah and
sending pictures and saying let's meet
up or whatever within minutes of making
a profile alive
and this ridiculous to think this
doesn't happen yeah
watch one more clip
literature of sound of freedom
Alejandro Monte Verde okay so we're
gonna look at an interview he did with
the local news last weekend police broke
up a major sex trafficking ring in
Colombia which has become a destination
for tourists looking for sex with boys
and girls the police had help from an
American who went undercover to rescue
the children and Elaine quijano met him
traffickers four months ago Colombian
authorities asked him to investigate a
tip that children were being sold there
as sex slaves within a half hour
this individual walks up to me starts
asking me what I'm here for what I want
and within minutes he says well I've got
I've got kids as young as 11 years old
Ballard a former Homeland Security agent
now heads up operation Underground
Railroad a non-profit group that rescues
trafficked kids after that first meeting
the Colombians asked him to put together
a sting no men will be in here only
women operation Underground Railroad
spent months planning renting this house
rigging it with hidden cameras to
document the crime coordinating with
Colombian authorities and negotiating
with the traffickers how they find these
kids is they lure them in by pretending
to have a modeling agency they target
them at nine or ten years old and they
were telling us that about by 11 they're
ready for sex they're ready to be sold
what is that like looking into that kind
of person's eyes it's horrifying and
this is why
because
I've got a smile in the face of evil
this is the table where we're going to
do the negotiation less than 24 hours
after the operatives landed the
suspected traffickers arrived on the
island and the final deal with the
undercover team began
54 boys and girls aged 11 to 18 were
ushered in for what had been billed as a
sex party they were given candy and
drinks and told to wait in this small
room this this little 11 year old boy I
remember he asked one of my operatives
if they could give him some cocaine or
something that he said they usually give
me something because I'm really scared
by the time the deal was done the
alleged traffickers were set to make 25
thousand dollars
that transaction was never completed
Colombian special operatives stormed the
party
arresting five suspects four men and one
former beauty queen
all charged with child trafficking
the victims 29 of whom are under 18 were
evacuated given medical exams and placed
in a rehabilitation center where
Specialists are working to undo the
damage right before I got on the boat we
had to walk by the this room where the
kids were and they put their hand up and
I touched their hand
and
see that there's Liberation now
liberating one child at a time
Elaine quijano CBS News New York
wow that's Noble wow interesting it's
interesting they keep saying he's
risking his life which is true he's also
risking the lives of his family in the
sense that he could have died at any
point leaving his wife a widow and his
children fatherless but God has been the
one
carrying him through keeping him alive
placing this burden on his heart and for
his wife to be in support of that
and to pretty much sacrifice her
relationship with him so that he can go
out and save all these children is
phenomenal it's phenomenal all the
things that he has sacrificed and this
is real like he's he's told his story in
interviews so not even putting aside the
movie looking at him as a person
looking at everything that he sacrificed
for this to be what the opposition is
coming up against us to be like no this
isn't real it's just beyond my scope of
understanding like like why yeah of all
the stories so to me it's like why not
media is seeing that the Hero part like
like this person decided you know what
I'm not going to be you know all the
money or I'm gonna be hanging out with
my family in Cancun
why I need to be wasting my time for two
months or I think in that same year he
was going to retire with pension yeah
and security
but because of that operation that they
wouldn't support it then he was like
okay I'm gonna go off and do my own
thing I mean that's beyond stuff I just
want to share with you guys some clip of
the movie and we're gonna know more more
facts about these shows
did you know there were over 22 million
new images of John pornography on the
web this past year
that's a five thousand percent increase
over the past five years
five thousand percent
the fact is
it is the fastest growing International
crime that work that the world has ever
seen
new 22 million
pictures new okay it's not like it was
before it was the new 22 million
pictures
in the last past year so these are the
statistics they have a problem with
it's interesting though they probably
saw this coming because after he says a
statistic he just says well the fact is
this is the fastest growing whether it's
5 000 or what have you this is the fast
this of all of them this is the fastest
growing it's disgusting and it's like
the the technology that we have today is
making it possible I mean when we were
growing up you take a picture take it to
somewhere they develop it I mean you'd
be busted unless you had your own like
like call that the dark room and all
that stuff but it's like you had to get
those pictures out physically and now
it's just like put on a website boom
it's out there worldwide I mean never
never in history have we been able to
distribute this kind of garbage like we
have today so yeah it makes sense I mean
ultimately technology always ends up in
the wrong hands eventually and yeah this
is why we have what we got and the
problem with pornography any pornography
is that it it's duplicated very quickly
so like women who have been trafficked
for pornography
uh come out saying like well I'm trying
to approach this particular website and
ask them to take my stuff down because I
would never I never consented to that I
was trafficked that was raped I was I
had to pretend like I was enjoying it to
make sure that I could stay alive and
get out right and so
that's what they tell these websites
they're like yeah don't take it down but
in the meantime it's been duplicated and
it's been uploaded to all these other
websites same thing will happen with
child pornography
wow
interesting
uh we see all this information but the
question is what are we gonna be doing
about this right and just I had this
small clip
of the movie and it deals with that with
this confrontation like okay this is the
the facts what you're gonna be doing
about this
way to it because we were working with
the US government to back out now this
whole thing will blow it has already
passed the illegal arm straight and soon
it's gonna pass the drug trade and you
want to know why
because you can sell a bag of cocaine
one time
but a child
the most precious child
you can tell a five-year-old kid
five to ten times a day
for 10 years straight
an everyday Ordinary People
I want to hear it
it's too ugly for polite conversation
but meanwhile over 2 million children a
year are being sucked into the deepest
recesses of hell
trust me man
if we do nothing
their pain is gonna spread and spread
so someday it's gonna reach the likes of
you
[Music]
and that will be a nightmare
you're never gonna wake up
yeah I I didn't watch the movie better
when I was researching this I mean it's
just like some anger inside like like he
was saying I mean
it's not a polite conversation I mean
you never had a conversation with me I
never had a conversation even though
when I was doing bad things in My Crazy
Life
I never had that garbage conversation no
even to do it or just like hey do you
know it's crazy world and they have this
and talk about that I mean that's beyond
I just it's just crazy when when I
watched the movie
I was having such a hard time just like
you I was having such a hard time not
crying I was with my fiance now she's
squeezing his hand the whole time
and again to think that people just want
to bash a movie like this people like
like how can you how can we talk about
child trafficking and pornography how
can we have a movie like this and people
all they want to do is trash it I don't
get it I just don't get it it doesn't
make sense because you look at stuff
like cuties came out on Netflix and it
glamorizes it and and it's like and
that's not the only movie I've seen
other movies some French film it's all
about some gay guy who's in love with a
young boy and like this stuff gets
glamorized and romanticized but then you
talk about the truth of what's really
happening and it gets bashed
that's that's the world we live in this
I think it's just signs of the times
hearts are growing cold good is evil
Evil's good and minor attractive persons
all this stuff
and like he said it's not a polite
conversation nobody wants to talk about
it and I can understand people maybe not
want to talk about it but to go against
it mind-blowing I can't understand it I
mean the Bible said that sin is gonna
grow I mean it's going to grow before G
is going to come and let me tell you
this is not what we see what the Bible
said I mean I don't know I mean we're
sleeping I mean I don't know I mean we
need to be ready and ready on just not
like just my salvation but also it's
like okay how we can help other people
one of the first
people need to do whoever watches
pornography needs to stop absolutely
because like this can only go on if
there's a demand right and people might
say well I don't watch child pornography
I just watch pornography of ladies that
are child porn stars and get paid for it
well I would refer those people to fight
the new drug and whatever you know they
have their blog and they have a page
called get the fact because and and to
their podcasts consider before consuming
because there are so many people out
there that are seen in pornography
videos that are portrayed as oh I'm
enjoying this and like I just explained
earlier uh a lot of them are traffic a
huge percentage of people men women are
trafficked where
um you know I heard a story of this lady
who was
um a fitness model and she legitimately
thought she was getting flown out for a
fitness model photo shoot and when she
reaches the hotel they force her to have
to uh do pornography and she basically
gets raped and if it hurts well sorry
but you have to act like you enjoying it
so we're gonna hurt you even more until
you pretend like you're enjoying it
um and then they locked her up and oh
she went to the bathroom finally when
they were done then they ordered Burgers
and Fries these things are happening in
pornography a huge percentage of uh
children are being trafficked as well
for sex and some of them though underage
are dressed up to look older that's
right they're dressed up to look older
so you don't even know what you're
dealing with or you're dealing with
child pornography who knows or there is
older women that they dress up like
children and so pornography messes with
your brain it gets you completely mixed
up to the point where people testify
like man I started with just pornography
or I started with masturbation then I
started watching pornography and then I
started getting into this and bestiality
and then I started getting into
um you know incest or child pornography
or
um racist pornography where black people
are being put down and abused and man it
just goes so far and like there's no end
to this there's no stop so if anybody
watching these things I can safely watch
pornography and I can do this and I will
never get there think again because this
is literally what's happening and that's
why God speaks against it in the Bible
no if they're not trafficked then they
could
be addicts that are just they're
enslaved and bondage with drugs it could
be just in a heart-up situation they're
doing the only thing they know how to do
or even if they're doing it willfully
they're so messed up in their mind that
they're exploiting themselves and one
day they will regret that and you are
supporting that you're supporting their
terrible decisions that they're making
at this point in their life that's I
mean that's just like having a
some kid that's making these really
crazy decisions doing drugs and you're
like you want some drugs I guess I mean
you're supporting the bad decisions
they're making yeah and you were talking
earlier about not wanting to fund the
organization that might put out one good
movie but a lot of bad movies man I can
guarantee you there's so many
pornography videos that people will
watch that they think is completely
kosher and safe but then they pay for
that and look on the other end they make
chop pornography that you might not even
know of right there's also no comparison
um in the way that in the Bible send us
in there's no like hierarchy of sin
looking at the extreme like oh well at
least I'm not sacrificing or like
drinking blood or you know or at least
I'm not rounding up the kids I'm just
you know I'm just in my room it's wrong
period there's no degrees to this so
whether we're looking at the so-called
extremes of so-called Q Anon or or
whatever the reason is like the fact is
this is happening it's wrong and it
should stop no yeah amen well I'm going
to be sharing with you guys at the end
of the this this program uh I'm gonna be
sharing with you guys uh the producer of
this movie
um Eduardo
says about Disney so don't don't finish
the whole the whole the whole show
because I'm gonna be sharing with you
guys the last the last clip that I have
but let me tell you people I don't know
if you you know about this uh tick
tocker uh very famous guy uh he went to
watch this movie
and it seems like he had a little
breakdown this guy his name is Chris
Rooney uh he has like 5.7 million
followers and he went to watch it and he
said that I mean it was very ill man he
went to the hospital because it was a
very uh you know uh the topic is not
like I enjoying the movie with your
popcorns you know what I'm saying like
it's very heavy so he went and decided
to go to the uh to the to the hospital
and said hey I need some help but let me
tell you he says prior to his
disappearance he has seen the movie
sound of freedom and like many others he
was sick to this court over it this
prompt him to post links raise money for
this cause of ending child self
trafficking wow so of course you know he
had some problems mental issues and he
went to watch a movie and he's like this
is so heavy and I'm like I need help and
he went to the hospital and I need to
check in you know
kind of response also happened with
Avatar yeah but no one posted links to
to fundraiser support for anything so of
course like you know this situation is
is unfortunate that that that's what
tipped him over the edge to get into
uh this institution and I'm happy that
he got the help that he needed but it's
it's admire admirable that it caused him
to act yeah that having that feeling
having those feelings prompted a sense
of urgency prompted an action to do good
and uh so with this kind of movie
it's not that heavy movies are bad you
know what I mean it's like exactly heavy
topics can be discussed they should be
discussed and the outcomes really let us
know what kind of topic we're actually
dealing with if that makes sense yeah
this is not a reason to not watch it
just because it's effective this guy
this way he's being exposed to something
that he probably didn't know was such a
big deal
um just like when I was talking about
the lady that would pretend to be 12 and
get on social media
like people that were the cops and
everything the people that were ready to
bust the guy were sick to their stomach
they'd have to leave like as soon as
they heard the comments that the guys
were making they just couldn't even
function and it's like this is a reality
this is really what's happening that's
why it's so heavy hitting like that
because you just we we expect people to
have some kind of decencies or morals we
expect the best of people you know
people are normally good is what we
think but no there's a lot of disgusting
disturbing things happening and that's
not to say people should watch it in the
sense of like yeah protect yourself like
if this is too heavy that's fine but
that's not a reason to not be informed
like you could still go read and
research or look to see how you can
prevent this happening to your family or
your community your sphere of influence
um so and I haven't seen it but I'm from
what I have seen and heard it it looks
like they
were very uh they weren't real explicit
about the way they displayed any of it
so it could have been a lot worse you
know yeah yeah and it is though in
fiction it is worse oh yeah I know
there's way more out there that's way
worse anyway yeah go ahead Alex and also
uh Rooney said that if there's one thing
that I have to learn during this time
there are a lot of hurting people and
this world and I'm going to do
everything I can help for amen praise
the Lord so I mean he's using his
platform and say you know what is it you
know you can donate this or you know
raise money for this cast for ending um
sex trafficking yeah so I had this clip
of people that want to go watch the
movie and something happened in the
movie theater they were not able to
watch the movie oh yeah look I don't
know if you heard of something like oh I
made a the gas something or the water in
the bathrooms are shut down or something
like that like oh no I thought uh
theaters were were not Banning it but
like either closing down or blocking
access to the film but you're talking
about actual things happening in the
theater yeah
so I have some clips so I'm sure as you
can find a lot of them in in social
media but I just want to have a few here
the whole country in different theaters
in this movie Only the AC doesn't work
it's like super sick really yeah
you should look online it's like it's
insane fire alarm goes off and people
still watch the movie they can't stop
the truth
[Music]
Freedom which is the Human Trafficking
movie by Jim Caviezel that's currently
outperforming uh Indiana Jones
but like for studios and everything are
trying to Hush Hush this movie and make
it seem like not so many people are
going to see it and they're not
promoting it at all and they're
basically trying to make it seem like no
one is going to see it
um theaters all over the country keep
having really weird things happen when
people go to see it like AC not working
sound networking like it's not turning
off
um and I was like super curious so I
came to see it and the lights didn't
turn off for the first 10 minutes and
also there was like a voiceover like a
narrator for blind people and so I could
like tell around me like tons of people
kept getting up to go complain and then
after about 15 minutes someone came in
and they turned the movie off and
someone came in and was like we can't
fix it so you all have to leave we're
gonna give you free passes and people
are like why this movie I've never had
this happen before and they're like we
can't turn the speaker off because we'd
have to go in a back room and like climb
a ladder to turn the speaker off and so
basically like we're gonna have to fix
it and they were like well it's been
playing for quite a while why is this
just happening now and they have like no
explanation
I'm just sitting out here finishing the
drink that I bought because I didn't get
to see a movie and like people were kind
of rumbling like oh I heard there's some
shady stuff going on around this movie
and now we're seeing it in person
and I'm just like wow like why doesn't
Hollywood want people to see this Jim
Caviezel Human Trafficking movie why
doesn't Hollywood want there to be
awareness around human trafficking and
pedophilia
I'm
flabbergasted I mean why wouldn't they
want to isn't that nuts though like has
anyone ever ever experienced that movie
before I've never experienced anything
like this in a movie so yeah I've never
gotten like kicked out of a movie 15
minutes in especially not a movie with
this you know
far-reaching implications wow that's
really interesting I agree with her I
mean I've it's not like I've been to a
ton of movies in the theater but as a
kid I didn't grow up Christian or
anything so I went to see went to the
theaters quite a bit and never has had
any issues with the movie theater never
I watched like a 16 minute video clip of
back-to-back things where people were
pulling out their phones like they were
being asked to leave for different
reasons a guy went to the like there's
like these automatic kiosks where you
can buy your ticket he said look at this
every single seat is sold out except for
the one in the front row there's one
seat opening the front row he was
clicking the ones to show you like it
says seat taking seat taking he said all
right I'm gonna buy this one in the
front row boom and he walks in and
there's like 10 people in the theater
so many open seats yet the kiosk was
saying every seat was sold and then um
yeah like Alex was saying there's things
like the bathrooms are having leaks and
just it's insane dude it's weird that's
really weird it's just insane we're
living in some
crazy time I mean seriously like I
cannot believe sometimes you're thinking
like never gonna happen come on 10 years
ago somebody told you you know like what
we're living right now and you're like
you dumb what are you talking about like
yeah we're living there I'm the kind of
person that if somebody tells me
conspiracy theory I'm like like I just
really stay away from it and I try to be
really down to earth but this is like
that's weird so this is the clip that we
I'm going to be sharing with you guys
the the producer of this movie uh
Eduardo uh is gonna be sharing about
what he thinks about Disney okay so this
guy uh Tim Butler uh went and met him
years before where like five years or
six years ago yeah it was it was
4q on
2015 or something interesting point yeah
when they're mad because this guy
Eduardo uh he came from Mexico and
wanted to be you know and and Hollywood
you know to Growing everything make
movies but the thing is that he was
learning English right and his English
teacher asked this question you know
it's kind of like a homework he said I
want to you practice your English right
now and talk about what is life
and he's like what is life
you can never ask me this question what
is life you know so he started writing
you know and it's like in that moment
it's like
what my life I'm going through like you
know drugs party and all stuff like what
I'm seeking that is not life hmm
and he decided to say you know what I'm
gonna be knocking the door in Hollywood
something that's not gonna be talking
bad about you know what I'm from all the
you know as a man you know just to get
the bad parts you know like you're a
drug dealer you know things like that
and I don't want to
um the the value of a woman I don't want
to destroy that that thing so that's
where his movies and when he was asking
some to be you know acting this and this
paper and in this movie uh he didn't get
that much up so he decided I need to
start making my own movie so he started
creating movies at Bella I don't know if
you guys watched the movie or Bella it
talks about
um abortion
and you know not to do it you know it's
a good message so you've been creating
you know good movies and when Tim baller
shared with him about this is the
stories and all the stuff and it's like
we need to we need to create this thing
like we need to do it and it that was
the beginning of of creating a song of
freedom and right now I just want to
share with you guys what he thinks about
Disney so listen to this
July we're competing with who we're
competing with Disney
who wants to corrupt your children
and sound of Freedom wants to save the
children
David against Goliath
you're David too that's right if we come
together as one David we know the end of
the story
Disney gets her head cut off
so where when do you use UC or hear an
actor a producer it talks about you know
what these want to destroy your children
yeah children stuff right yeah I mean
and this film
it's going to be helping saving your
children and also he said you know from
the Bible say you know you know the
story about David Golia right he said we
are little babies you know what's the
end of story everyone plugged in knows
like they know that and even Disney is
very
uh upfront about their plans for
children and what they're gonna do and
so what's really happening is the the
top people or actors producers they're
just not talking about they're not
coming forward and and saying things
like the like the agenda thing promotion
of that stuff and then those who do and
are against it they're the ones who come
out as crazy or we don't hear from them
for a while and but they're protecting
their own circles they're protecting
their kids they're the ones not giving
their kids phones until they're
teenagers
um they don't watch their move the kids
don't watch their parents movies all
this kind of stuff but yeah where is the
general public they're championing on
and they're relying on us to do that so
that they can keep going and doing their
agendas yeah and I think it's ironic
that sometimes in our comment section
people say you're the reason that people
aren't Christians and it's like they'll
bash what we're saying just because
we're like look this movie is blatantly
glamorizing the occult blatantly
glamorizing the LGBT agenda and all this
stuff and it's like they'll protect
those movies they'll protect that
entertainment but yet bash their own
brothers and sisters who are simply
pointing it out yeah like we're not just
like making stuff up we're like look
here it is and then we're the enemy
it's interesting yeah we're the enemy of
the devil and unfortunately people allow
themselves to be used by the devil
and anyway as as the Director uh the
producer producer just said we know how
the story ends so we just need to be
faithful in our work amen yeah stay on
the side of David
and even if it doesn't happen our
lifetime vengeance is the Lord's all
Wicked people will receive the just
punishment and people need to repent I
mean because the Lord does want to save
that's right like that's something I do
want to emphasize is like we don't want
to sit here and just bash
people that you know put out Hollywood
movies that are promoting via cult or
anything satanic or anti-christian we
don't want to sit there and do that we
want to say those are people that God
also wants to save and there's hope for
those people yeah you know Jesus died
for everyone and he and we are exposing
these things because we want
people to understand what's going on so
that they can make a decision for Jesus
if they so choose if they choose to do
so yeah and that's the beauty of the
Gospel yeah and powerful thing that
somebody is it was so corrupted is going
to say you know what because I come to
know Jesus Christ that he's my savior
now I'm a new creature I mean that's the
crazy yeah and I believe and I believe
this that we're gonna hear those
testimonies yeah you know that's if
people are at home watching pornography
watching child pornography
you know attractions for children or
whatever their sin is like Jesus can set
those people free they can say but then
he wants to save There's Hope for
everyone every single person on this
Earth
has hope in Jesus that they can change
and repent and they can become beautiful
people when they receive the Holy Spirit
when they accept Jesus in their hearts
okay you guys I hope you enjoy one this
episode this episode about sound of
freedom I know many people have you been
asking about what is your reaction you
guys going to be talking about this and
I just wanted to tell you thank you for
your support and we can make videos like
this uh if you want to go to patreon.com
littlelife Studio support us there don't
forget to like And subscribe in your
channel because let me tell you that's
gonna be help us to grow and to to share
this share this just this video this
discussion and I hope this this message
was a a huge I should help we need to be
awareness of this also if you guys want
to check out some T-shirts we all are
wearing some
go lightwear dot shop and check them out
and you can support us that way and we
also have a podcast if you want to dig
deep into the Bible and discover the
truth of God's word check out Little
Light Studios podcast on whatever
podcasting platform you listened and we
have little less Studios and espanol oh
yeah we have Little X Studios
International yeah little like kids
see some things that are educational
bible-based we get a lot of people ask
what can we watch you guys tell us all
the stuff we can't watch and it's not
easy it's not it's pretty much
impossible for us to say this is safe to
watch because hey even Arnold or Arthur
had a gay wedding and stuff like that so
uh subscribe to little light kids it's
new but we need your support to help us
produce more content that's safe for
children another way you can support us
is through our website
littlelightstudios.tv if you'd like to
donate you can go to lls.tv slash give
and we also have a bunch of content on
there our DVDs are on there you can find
stickers free posters and there are many
resources available as well Bible
studies and all of that so check it out
and we'll see you next week on LED live
bye
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little
light kids
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Bible studies are on there as well so
give that website a a what a look a
check
check it out check it out
and there are many resources available
as well Bible studies and all of that so
check it out
and we'll see you next week on LED live
bye
[Music]